.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
2019 lernten wir
auf der grossen SRF DOK-Expedition
mit Hundeschlitten
quer durch Lappland
Silvia kennen.
Sie war als Teilenehmerin dabei.
Für die damals 46-Jährige
ging damit ein fast
unerreichbarer Traum in Erfüllung.
Denn vier Jahre zuvor
erhielt sie die Diagnose Parkinson.
Allen Widrigkeiten zum Trotz
zog sie die fünftägige Tour durch,
bei teils -30 °C.
Dank Medikamenten
und v.a. ihrem starken Willen,
der uns tief beeindruckte.
* Jauchzer *
Wenn man will, kann man alles.
Auch mit meiner Krankheit.
Ich bin stolz.
Andere können das auch,
wenn sie sich trauen.
Man muss sich einfach trauen
und Mut haben.
Mut hatte ich jetzt, glaube ich.
Es war super.
Schön.
Das gibt mir immer wieder Kraft.
Wenn ich morgens
nicht aufstehen kann,
weil ich steif bin ...
... denke ich daran, dass ich dort
den Hügel runtergefahren bin.
"Jetzt machst du auch das."
* Mystische Musik *
Wir wollten sie weiterbegleiten.
Ein Jahr später ist vieles anders
im Leben von Silvia.
Ich bin weniger fit.
Ich muss alle drei bis vier Stunden
Tabletten nehmen.
Dopamin,
um den Dopaminspiegel zu heben,
sonst falle ich in ein Off.
Und diese Offs
sind jeweils sehr mühsam:
verkrampfte Hand und Gesichtszüge,
die nicht mehr so emotional wirken.
Darauf sprechen mich die Leute
jeweils an:
"Geht es dir heute nicht gut?"
Dann habe ich Versteifungen,
bin verlangsamt -
im Reden oder auch in der Stimme,
die auch ...
... plötzlich
leiser wird und versagt.
Manchmal kommen mir auch Wörter
nicht mehr in den Sinn.
Einfach so kognitive Dinge,
die jetzt doch auch ...
... vorkommen.
* Klingeln *
Was ist das?
Das ist mein Medikamentenalarm.
Mittlerweile
lasse ich mich erinnern.
Sonst vergesse ich,
die Medikamente zu nehmen.
Meistens alle drei Stunden.
Parkinson ist
eine degenerative Nervenkrankheit,
die nicht heilbar ist,
die für Silvia
immer weniger möglich macht.
Sie benötigt immer mehr Medikamente,
um den Botenstoff Dopamin
zu ersetzen,
der im Hirn
nicht mehr produziert wird.
Silvia ist inzwischen
am Limit mit den Tabletten,
welche die Schmerzen
und Symptome unterdrücken.
Das ist meine Medikamentenkiste.
Ich kann für jeden Tag
so eine Box richten.
Ich brauche eine am Morgen,
eine um 11 Uhr,
eine um 13.30 Uhr ...
... eine um 16.30 Uhr ...
... eine um 19 Uhr und dann eine ...
... auf die Nacht, um 22 Uhr.
Genau.
Eins, zwei ...
Ja, das sollte reichen.
Doch ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt
wirken auch diese Medikamente
nicht mehr.
Das ist die Phase,
in der die Ärzte dann sagen ...
... ich müsse doch mal
an eine Alternativlösung ...
... denken.
In meinem Falle ist das die THS.
Die Tiefe Hirnstimulation.
Die Tiefe Hirnstimulation
ist eine Operation,
bei der Silvia zwei Sonden
ins Hirn operiert würden.
Diese normalisieren über Stromimpulse
die Funktion in den Hirnregionen,
in denen
die Krankheit Parkinson entsteht.
So bin ich ausgerüstet
für eine Weile.
Jetzt habe ich auch Überbewegungen.
Das sieht man am Bein.
Das ist kein Zittern,
das sind Überbewegungen.
Die habe ich nicht im Griff.
Ich muss lernen,
sie in den Griff zu kriegen.
Das kackt mich an.
Denn jetzt sieht man,
dass irgendetwas nicht gut ist.
Silvia ist seit 17 Jahren
in einer Beziehung.
Sie reiste viel, tauchte und
nahm sogar an einem Gigathlon teil.
Diese Energie und den Willen
hat sie nicht verloren.
Als bei ihr mit 42 Jahren
Parkinson diagnostiziert wurde,
hat sie unter dem Namen "Move4YPD"
eine Selbsthilfegruppe für
junge Parkinsonerkrankte gegründet.
Heute treffen sie sich
zum ersten Tischtennistraining.
Ihr Ziel: Nächstes Jahr wollen sie
an den Parkinson-Tischtennis-Welt-
meisterschaften in Berlin teilnehmen.
Mittlerweile ist es ein Verein.
Vorher
war es eine "Selbsthilfegruppe".
Aber wir wollen es nicht so nennen.
Darum heissen wir "Move4YPD".
Also: move - Bewegung, 4 - für,
YPD -
junge parkinsonerkrankte Menschen.
Herzlich willkommen.
Ich freue mich mega,
dass so viele hier sind.
Wirklich: Danke vielmals,
dass ihr den Weg gefunden habt.
Wir haben heute das Meet4Parkinson,
da machen wir alle drei Monate
einen Anlass.
Es ist das erste Training
der schweizerischen Parkinson-
Tischtennisnationalmannschaft.
* Lachen *
Einmal pro Monat
gibt es den Monatshöck.
Die Leute
können sich über Skype zuschalten
oder physisch kommen.
So gibt es
einen beständigen Austausch.
Wir sind fast eine kleine Familie.
Man kennt sich langsam.
Es ist eine Familie
mit inzwischen 70 Mitgliedern -
Tendenz steigend.
Betroffene
sind Menschen mitten im Leben.
Von einer Krankheit,
die in der Gesellschaft
immer noch als Alterskrankheit
wahrgenommen wird.
(Frau) Sehr gut.
Kurz und lang - egal. Sehr gut.
Ein weiteres Ziel ihres Vereins
sei es deshalb,
dieses Bild in der Öffentlichkeit
zu korrigieren
und Parkinson
ein Gesicht zu geben, meint Silvia.
Wie ehrgeizig bist du im Sport?
Sehr.
Sehr was?
- Sehr ehrgeizig.
Wenn es mich packt, will ich
das Ziel erreichen, wenn möglich.
Dann werde ich fast ...
... etwas aggressiv, manchmal.
(Frau) Genau, beide da vorne ...
Gut.
Sechs Monate später
treffen wir sie wieder
Inzwischen ist bei Silvia der Parki,
wie sie ihn nennt,
so weit fortgeschritten,
dass sie nur noch 40 %
als Softwaretesterin arbeiten kann.
Am Anfang der Krankheit
waren es 80 %.
Das ging gut -
bis ungefähr drei oder vier Jahre
nach der Diagnose.
Als die ersten ...
... Symptome kamen,
die stärker waren als am Anfang.
Da konnte ich auf 50 % und dann
auch auf 40 % runterschrauben.
Das klappte einwandfrei,
mit dem HR und der IV.
Gut, dort musste ich zweimal
eine Runde drehen.
Aber das klappte wirklich super.
Ich bin dankbar und froh.
Auch die Tabletten
verlieren immer mehr ihre Wirkung.
Silvia kämpft
um ein möglichst normales Leben.
Sie versucht den Parkinson
in die Schranke zu weisen,
um aktiv zu bleiben.
Manchmal
mag ich abends gar nicht mehr.
Heute ist aber gut.
Ich kann in die Musik.
Ich denke, heute ist gut.
Ich habe hier noch vorbereitet.
Eine zusätzliche Tablette,
die ich um 20 Uhr nehme.
So ein Schnellwirker.
Damit ich sicher
eine Stunde durchalten mag.
Nach über einem halben Jahr Pause
wegen Corona
findet heute Abend die erste Probe
ihrer Brassband statt.
Musik gebe ich als Letztes auf
wegen dieser Krankheit.
Die mache ich,
solange es irgendwie geht.
Wenn ich nicht mehr
mit den Fingern drücken kann ...
... wechsle ich zur Posaune.
Dort muss man ziehen.
Es gibt auch dort die Möglichkeit,
eine Lösung zu finden.
Oder am Schluss dann die Pauke.
* Sie lacht. *
* Ruhige Blasmusik *
Ironie des Schicksals:
Ausgerechnet bei den Musikproben
wurden bei ihr vor zehn Jahren
die ersten Symptome
der Krankheit entdeckt.
Ich konnte die Läufe mit den Fingern
nicht mehr so schnell machen.
Ich konnte Tonleitern
nicht mehr schnell spielen,
weil die Finger nicht mehr
so runtergingen, wie sie sollten.
Ich konnte meine Stimme
nicht mehr spielen.
Der Dirigent sagte immer,
ich müsse mehr üben.
Es ging einfach nicht,
obwohl ich zu Hause übte.
Dann konnte ich
auch andere Dinge nicht mehr machen.
Z.B. die Haare waschen usw.
Dann ging ich zum Neurologen
und es kam aus,
dass die rechte Hand ...
Und mit links
kann ich eben nicht spielen.
Ja, dass es mit der rechten Hand
nicht mehr ging.
Bis zur Diagnose Parkinson
vergingen weitere zwei Jahre.
Zuerst vermutete man
eine körperliche Einschränkung.
Als sich nichts änderte,
wurden weitere
neurologische Abklärungen gemacht -
erst dann auch auf Parkinson,
da Silvia ja eigentlich zu jung sei
für eine solche Diagnose.
Ich wusste, dass meine Grossmutter
das auch hatte.
Aber Altersparkinson.
Und ...
Ich hoffte aber,
dass es nicht das ist.
Ich hoffte, es sei etwas,
das man operativ machen kann.
Schnell den Karpaltunnel öffnen
und dann ist gut.
Als sie mir das sagte -
das war wie ein Schlag ins Gesicht.
Bäm.
Ein Schlag ins Gesicht.
Ja.
* Ruhige Blasmusik *
Von einem Moment auf den anderen
ist nichts mehr wie zuvor.
Hoi, Schätzchen.
- Hoi.
Auch für ihren Lebenspartner Thomas.
Er war dabei,
als die Diagnose Gewissheit wurde.
Cervelat?
- Gerne.
Das war im Spital in Olten.
Wir waren draussen auf einer Bank.
Wir hatten eine Vermutung,
aber keinen ...
... konkreten Bescheid.
Für den definitiven Bescheid ...
... musstest du zur Ärztin.
Und ich wartete draussen.
Die Bank kennen wir heute noch.
Wir sassen draussen
und weinten zusammen.- Mhm.
Ja. Aber der ...
... Entschluss ...
... das so mitzunehmen,
war getroffen, als wir aufstanden.
Schon da.
- Ja.
Das ist jetzt das, was es ist.
- Mhm.
Und wir machen das Beste daraus.
Also ...
Man kann es ja nicht ändern.
Nein.
- Man muss das annehmen.- Mhm.
Ja, das ist das Wichtigste.
Das passierte dort schon.- Mhm.
Ja.
Akzeptieren und weitergehen -
auch in der Beziehung.
Sie wurde intensiver, finde ich.
Mhm.
Und auch ruhiger.
- Ja.
Ja.
Du willst ja leben.
- Mhm.
Mhm. Und es möglichst geniessen.
Eigentlich ...
* Lachen *
Eigentlich haben wir auf der Bank
vor dem Spital beschlossen ...
Ja.
... dass wir nie mehr
miteinander streiten.
Die Zeit und Energie,
die man dafür aufwendet ...
... kann man anderweitig einsetzen.
Es gibt ja gar keinen Grund dafür.
Diskutieren, aber nicht streiten.
- Absolut. Genau.
Mhm.
Kompromissbereitschaft soll da sein.
Wir finden auch immer
irgendeinen Kompromiss.
Mhm.
Einen Monat später
teilt uns Silvia mit,
nun sei die Operation
ihre letzte Chance.
Mit ihrem Göttibub ist
sie unterwegs zum Unispital Zürich,
wo der sog. Levodopa-Test
stattfindet.
Er zeigt, ob sie für die Operation
infrage kommt oder nicht.
Seit gestern Abend durfte sie
keine Medikamente mehr nehmen,
um den Ist-Zustand der Krankheit
möglichst unverfälscht zu sehen.
Gestern hatte ich Angst.
"Was, wenn nicht?"
Aber daran denke ich jetzt nicht.
Die Anzeichen stehen auf gut.
Jetzt gehe ich hin.
Ich muss da durch.
Das hier ist nicht nur für mich,
sondern für alle ...
Kraft gibt ihr in solchen Momenten
der Song "Der Weg"
von Herbert Grönemeyer,
in der Version des an Parkinson
erkrankten Sängers Gunnar Sar.
* Melancholische Ballade *
# Die Jahre vergeh'n.
# Ich kämpf' immer noch weiter.
# Etwas anderes geht nicht.
# Aufgeb'n ist keine Option.
# Ich werde nicht jammern.
# Dafür leb' ich zu gerne.
# Jeden Tag wieder.
* Sie stöhnt. *
# Guten Tag, Parkinson.
(Frau)
Einen wunderschönen, guten Morgen.
Ich habe es fast geschafft.
- Hallo, Frau Lerch.
Geht es? Können Sie noch gehen?
Das geht noch gut,
aber die Krämpfe ...
Okay. Treten Sie ein.
Es ist gemein, wenn ich das sage,
aber ich freue mich,
wenn es Ihnen heute schlecht geht.
Es geht ja im heutigen Test darum,
den schlechten Zustand
mit dem besten zu vergleichen.
Die Symptome,
die auf Levodopa ansprechen ...
Sie können davon ausgehen,
dass sich das auch unter der
tiefen Hirnstimulation verbessert.
Gut.
Wie hoch würden Sie den Krampf
im linken Fuss einschätzen?
Von 0 bis 10? 0 ist kein Schmerz,
10 der schlimmste vorstellbare.
Acht.
- Acht.
Ich darf Sie jetzt bitten,
mit der rechten Hand
Daumen und Zeigefinger
gross und schnell
auf- und zuzutippen.
Und mit links, bitte.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt bitte mit der rechten Hand
die Faust gross und schnell
auf- und zumachen.
Und mit links, bitte.
Bitte nochmals mit Rechts.
Gut. Danke schön.
* Schluchzen *
Es ist schon krass,
wenn man sieht ...
... was im Off alles ...
... nicht mehr geht.
- Mhm.
Das kann ich gut verstehen.
Es macht
natürlich auch immer bewusst,
wie abhängig man
von diesen Medikamenten ist.
Mhm.
Wahnsinn.
- Gut.
Nun kommt auch ihr behandelnder Arzt,
Prof. Baumann, dazu.
So, wie geht es?
- Hm ...
* Gequältes Lachen *
Na ja ...
Mittelprächtig?
- Mittelprächtig. Ja, in etwa.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden:
Es geht Ihnen jetzt so schlecht,
wie sonst nicht.
Nein, so schlimm war es noch nie.
Noch nie? Der schlechteste Zustand
überhaupt.- Ja.
Eine gute Nachricht haben wir,
das hat Frau Uhl schon gesagt:
Das ist genau das,
was wir sehen wollen.
Wir wollen die schlechteste Seite
des Parkinsons sehen.
Jetzt schauen wir,
wie es Ihnen besser geht.
Wir warten nicht lange
und geben das Medikament.
Dann wünschen wir viel Glück
und schnelle Erholung.
Bis nachher.
- Ja.
Hoffentlich
in einem anderen Zustand.
Wir sind ziemlich sicher ...
- Bestimmt.
... dass dem so sein wird.
Silvia durchläuft noch einmal
dieselben Tests wie zuvor,
nun aber
unter Einfluss der Medikamente.
Wie geht es Ihnen jetzt?
Wieder super.
- Super.
Ich darf Sie bitten,
mit der rechten Hand
Daumen und Zeigefinger,
gross und schnell.
Und das Gleiche mit links.
Sehr gut.
Ich darf Sie bitten,
mit der rechten Hand
die Faust gross und schnell
auf- und zuzumachen.
Und mit links, bitte.
Sehr gut.
Gut. Wunderbar.
Sie haben das grossartig gemacht.
Es ist ein riesiger Unterschied
zwischen dem Off-Zustand morgens ...
... und dem On-Zustand
nach der Medikation.
Gut.
Sie haben eine ganz andere Mimik.
Jetzt sieht man die Lachfalten.
Genau.
Geht es besser?
- Viel besser.
Tag und Nacht?
- Ja.
Sie hat hervorragend profitiert.
Damit haben Sie locker bestanden.
* Lachen *
Das ist ein überdurchschnittlich
gutes Ansprechen.
Das hat Frau Uhl
sicher schon gesagt.
Man kann nichts versprechen
bei der Operation.
Aber grundsätzlich gilt: Je besser
jemand auf den Test anspricht,
desto grösser ist die Chance,
dass die Operation etwas bringt.
Super. Danke vielmals.
- Prima. Danke Ihnen.
Und Gratulation. Sehr schön.
* Melancholische Ballade *
# Du wolltest mein Leben
so richtig durchschütteln.
# Und du versuchst es jeden Tag neu.
# Bis einer weint
und dann reich' ich dir einen Teil,
# um mich an meinem Leben
zu erfreu'n.
Die Operation ist ein Schritt,
der für Silvia und Thomas
v.a. mit viel Hoffnung verbunden ist.
Dass man das erfüllte Leben ...
... weiterführen kann.
In einer Form, in der du
weniger Schmerzen hast und ...
... wo es dir besser geht
und dir wohl ist.
Wir machen das heute schon gut
und für uns richtig.
Aber dass wir das noch lange
so weitermachen können ...- Ja.
Ja.
Dass wir spontan sein können
und auch mal ...
... in die Naturhüttenfreunde
raufgehen können an einem Sonntag.
Solche Dinge,
ohne dass ich am Montag flachliege.
Naturfreundehütten.
- Naturfreundehütten.
Ja.
- Genau.- Genau.
Habe ich es verkehrt gesagt?
- Ja.
Shit.
- Macht nichts.
Ich kann es nie richtig sagen.
Der grosse Tag.
Silvia
hat sich mental darauf vorbereitet
und die Operation
in Abschnitte eingeteilt.
Wie damals
die Schlittenhundetour in Lappland.
Mit dabei: Maskottchen Slushy.
Es gibt einen Plan,
wie du das machen möchtest.
Dass ich dort ...
... mental die Bilder
wieder vor Augen habe.
Dass ich die abrufen und sagen kann:
"Dolly, bring mich ans Ziel."
Dolly war mein Leithund.
Ja.
Ich habe schon auch etwas Angst.
Aber ich will das.
Ich will da durch
und ein besseres Leben haben.
Silvia muss während
der ganzen Operation wach sein,
damit sie Rede und Antwort
stehen kann.
Zuerst werden am Kopf
die Stellen gekennzeichnet,
wo die Sonden
ins Hirn eingepflanzt werden sollen.
Jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich mühsam.
Danach werden durch die Schädeldecke
die Kanäle
für die beiden Sonden gelegt ...
... bevor Professor Baumann
als Neurologe dazukommt.
Er begleitet die Operation.
Grüezi, Frau Lerch.
- Guten Morgen.
Geniessen Sie es?
- Äh ...
Geht so?
- Es geht so.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Äh ...
Ich bin müde.
- Nicht gut geschlafen?
Nein.
- Ja.
Können Sie Zeigefinger und Daumen
gross und schnell auf- und zumachen?
Auch hier werden vor der Operation
wieder Funktionstests gemacht -
damit kontrolliert werden kann,
wie sich die Symptome
unter der Stimulation verbessern.
Schneller geht nicht? Das
reicht nicht fürs Pingpongspielen.
Im Gegensatz zum Levodopa-Test
werden es nun die Sonden sein,
welche die Funktion im Gehirn
normalisieren
und nicht die Medikamente.
Deshalb werden sie
nun an die Stelle im Hirn eingeführt,
wo die Funktion bei Parkinson
fehlerhaft ist.
-8,5.
Millimeter um Millimeter
tastet sich das Team heran.
-6,5.
Auf einem Bildschirm
werden die Signale
von Silvias Hirnzellen überwacht.
Die Ruhe vor dem Sturm.
* Rauschen *
Das Rauschen zeigt,
dass sich die Sonde in
der angestrebten Hirnregion befindet.
* Rauschen *
Ja, das stimmt.
Frau Lerch,
Sie sind wie ein Anatomiebuch.
Wir haben alles gesehen.
- Ehrlich?
Schritt für Schritt.
Jetzt sind wir da,
wo es am besten ist.
Jetzt stellen wir den Strom an.
- Ja.
Eins.
Wir schauen noch mal hier.
Prima. Das geht "Schlegel a Wegge".
Kennen Sie diesen Ausdruck auch?
* Lachen *
Nein.
- Altes Zürichdeutsch.
So, wir können auf zwei gehen.
Zwei.
So.
Jetzt haben Sie das,
was Sie mit den Medikamenten haben.
Ja.
Gross auf- und zumachen.
Gross und schnell.
Sehr schön, Frau Lerch.
- Mhm.
Wunderbar. Noch etwas mehr Strom.
Drei.
Super, Frau Lerch. Es sieht gut aus.
- Ja.
Schön, dass es wie im Bilderbuch
läuft, wenn das Fernsehen da ist.
Wunderbar.
Soll ich Thomas anrufen?
- Mhm.
Mhm? Was soll ich ihm sagen.
Dass es gut gegangen ist.
Mhm.
- Sehr gut gegangen.
Okay, gut.
Ich bin gleich wieder da. Okay?
Sie macht das wirklich toll.
Sie können
extrem stolz auf sie sein.
Sehen Sie.
Sind Sie auch erleichtert?
Sind das Tränen der Erleichterung?
Mhm.
Ich soll Sie
auch ganz lieb von ihr grüssen.
Es ist alles sehr gut gegangen.
Jetzt machen wir die zweite Seite.
Parallel dazu läuft dasselbe
Prozedere auf der rechten Hirnseite.
Auch hier sprechen Silvias
angepeilten Hirnregionen sehr gut an.
So, Sie haben es geschafft,
Frau Lerch.- Ja. Juhu.
Sie haben das tipptopp gemacht.
Danke für die gute Zusammenarbeit.
- Danke auch.
Wie heisst er? Slushy?
Der hat Ihnen geholfen.- Ja.
Auf Wiedersehen, Frau Lerch.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Man dankt.
- Danke schön.
Nach über 3 Std. werden die Sonden
ins Hirn eingepflanzt,
die in Zukunft die Hirnfunktionen
Tag und Nacht normalisieren
und ein Leben lang wirken.
Geheilt ist Silvia aber nicht.
Sie wird den Parki nicht los.
Da müssen wir
mit offenen Karten spielen.
Es ist eine symptomatische Therapie.
Es braucht auch nachher Medikamente.
Im Schnitt zwei Drittel weniger
bei unseren Patienten,
aber auf null geht es selten.
Man spürt ihn immer wieder,
hoffentlich aber viel weniger.
Ein halbes Jahr
später besuchen wir Silvia.
Wieder ist alles anders.
Wenn der blaue Schrank
draussen ist ...
Silvia und Thomas ziehen um.
Die beiden erfüllen sich den Traum
von einem eigenen Haus zur Miete.
Neuer Tatendrang
und sich auf etwas freuen -
obwohl es müde macht.
Aber man kann sich auf etwas freuen.
Kannst du mal rüber?
Schon seit Tagen
hat Silvia mit angepackt.
Immer ein bisschen, nicht zu viel.
Auch der Umgang mit den Medikamenten
hat sich verändert.
Wie geht es dir jetzt körperlich?
Ich bin schon etwas müde.
Ja, schon etwas müde.
Aber es ist bald 11 Uhr.
Ah, bald ist 11 Uhr. Genau.
* Schnalzen *
So.
Weil ich schon um 6.15 Uhr
eine genommen habe,
kann ich sie etwas früher nehmen.
Sonst einfach alle 4 Std.
Einmal Levodopa.
Fertig.
Wie viele Tabletten weniger
musst du jetzt nehmen?
Zwei Drittel.
Und das funktioniert?
- Mhm.
Was heisst das für dich?
- Freiheit.
Eine Freiheit und
natürlich auch weniger Medikamente,
weniger Belastung für den Körper.
Weniger Nebenwirkungen.
Hättest du das, was du heute machst,
ohne die Operation
durchziehen können?
Nein.
Als wir uns für die Operation
entschieden hatten,
war das ja kein Thema.
So etwas, also ein Haus.
Wenn ich die Operation
nicht gemacht hätte,
hätten wir uns dagegen entschieden.
Kurz nach der Operation
fiel Silvia in ein Loch.
Die falschen Medikamente
wurden abgesetzt,
wie sich im Nachhinein herausstellte.
Danach begann das Ausprobieren:
Medikamente runter, Strom rauf -
streng nach Plan.
Ein stetiges Ausloten und Versuchen.
Eine Achterbahnfahrt,
bis sie richtig eingestellt war.
Ich habe auch wieder mehr Energie -
aber erst seit rund zwei Monaten.
Vorher war das
schon etwas deprimierend.
"Ich habe den Schritt gemacht,
jetzt sollte es besser sein."
Und trotzdem hatte ich Tage,
an denen es mir schlecht ging
und ich nicht sehr beweglich war.
Schmerzen habe ich keine mehr.
Aber ich dachte: "Ich habe den
ganzen Scheiss auf mich genommen,
und habe nicht mehr Benefits davon."
Das hat mich manchmal ...
Ja ...
Aber keine so grossen Löcher mehr,
dass ich
morgens nicht aufstehen wollte.
Das ist natürlich Lebensqualität,
wenn man
nicht ständig Tabletten nehmen muss
und ständig in die Offs reinkommt.
So wurde es auch ruhiger,
gemütlicher.
Das Leben.
Ich habe massiv mehr Lebensqualität.
Ja, so ist fein.
So ist fein. Ja.
Ich mache dir etwas Wind.
Und zu dieser Lebensqualität
gehört auch Armin,
der achtmonatige Deutsche Pinscher.
Benannt nach einen Teammitglied
der Lapplandreise.
Er gehört inzwischen fix zur Familie.
Armin gibt Silvia
eine Tagesstruktur und eine Aufgabe,
da sie noch nicht arbeiten kann.
Hier. Was macht man?
Es ist schon ein Neuanfang, oder?
- Ja, alles.
Alles. Der Hund, das Haus ...
Wir müssen noch einrichten
und Dinge aufbauen.
Und was nachher kommt,
weiss ich gar nicht.
Drei Jahre
haben wir Silvia nun begleitet
auf ihrem Weg mit Parkinson.
Ein Weg mit vielen Hochs und Tiefs.
Ein Weg, der sie prägte und der
ihre Sicht aufs Leben verändert hat.
Ich sehe das heute
vielleicht anders.
Weil ich mich ...
* Armin niest. *
Weil ich mich einschränken muss,
muss ich anders planen.
Und ich lerne v.a. anderes kennen.
Ja.
Auch mit den Leuten in der Gruppe.
Ich lerne
so viele gute Leute kennen,
die auch Power haben.
Auch in der Tischtennisgruppe.
Der Spirit, den wir haben,
ist wahnsinnig.
Die hätte ich sonst
nie kennengelernt.
Ja, das ist ...
Ja ...
Wenn man das Demut nennen kann,
ist es das.
Thomas meint, es sei kein Anfang,
es sei ein Weitergehen auf dem Weg
von Silvias Leben mit Parkinson -
hoffentlich etwas weniger steinig.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022